foreign
[Music]
hello everybody I am Nick Gillespie and
this is the reason live stream thank you
for joining uh we are going to be uh
joined today by Connor boyak the
president of the libertas Institute and
Corey DeAngelis
uh who is uh up here now hello guys can
I uh can you both say hello please
hello please hey how's it going all
right it's good to see you uh they are
most recently the the co-authors of
mediocrity 40 ways that government
schools are failing today's students and
we're going to talk about that book and
a bunch of other stuff
um so
um I guess what I want to do I'm going
to play a couple of uh slides here that
include uh
uh
uh and I just want to I'm going to ask
our
um my backstage manager uh best buyers
if you could make sure that we're
recording this correctly
all right all right great okay so
um I want to start with a slide uh this
is from a nation at risk uh mediocrity
your new book
um it starts with a you know it's citing
a 1983 report that was put together by a
commission on education Excellence a
federal panel uh that
um made this bold statement and in many
ways this uh a nation at risk kind of
started uh one of the latest kind of uh
you know spurts and education reform
although if we're being honest education
reform has been a constant concern since
the colonial period of America but here
we have a nation at risk which jump
started a lot of discussion of Education
reform in 1983 40 years ago if an
unfriendly foreign power had attempted
to impose on America the mediocre
educational performance that exists
today we might have well viewed it as as
an act of War as it stands we've allowed
this to happen to ourselves we have even
squandered the gains in student
achievement made in the wake of the
Sputnik challenge Sputnik launched in
the late 50s moreover we have dismantled
essential support systems which help
make those gains possible we have in
effect been committing an un an act of
unthinking unilateral education
disarmament
um Connor why don't we start with you
what um you know uh what was the context
for a nation at risk and how does that
kind of undergird
continuing or contemporary interests in
in school reform
uh Nick as you point out uh education
reform has been a long-standing concern
certainly in the decades preceding this
report there had been in the press in
the Years prior to the report being
issued a large number of you know op-eds
and complaints and people criticizing
the poor performance of the education
system and so this group The National
Commission on excellence in education
was formed in large part to address
those concerns and bring attention to
the the plight of the problem the pleas
of so many who were saying hey we got to
do something to fix it they spent 18
months going across the country on
basically a listening tour talking to
teachers and administrators and students
and others reviewing curriculum and
standards and the report that you just
read an excerpt from is the culmination
of that 18-month study they called it an
open letter to the American people and
it did use strong language such as the
the excerpt that you just read in part
to try and go organize the public into
realizing that this was a slow slide
into mediocrity this slowly Rising tide
the an actual Rising tide often catches
people if it's a Riptide you know
swimmers are often unaware
um and uh it's you know then too late
for them to to do anything about it the
purpose of the report was to kind of be
the warning sign on the beach to say hey
be careful there's a slowly emerging
tide here you should you know act
accordingly
and this was also uh you know uh the
Department of Education uh as a cabinet
level agency had only been created in
the late 70s under Jimmy Carter
um and then uh Ronald Reagan originally
ran on on saying he was going to get rid
of it uh but he kept it
and this nation at risk really helped
Galvanize his uh uh you know attempts in
the 80s both under Reagan and then under
George H.W bush
um you know kind of the need for school
reform Corey can you talk a little bit
about what what were the emphases on
school reformer education reform uh
starting in the in the 1980s into the
early 90s
yeah a lot of this was uh accountability
mechanisms and mostly focused on
standardized tests uh but what I want to
say is that
the the failures have have changed and
have become much Beyond much further
Beyond uh what can be captured by a
standardized test score and what we're
seeing more recently is and what we
highlight in the book is a lot of the
non-academic failures of the school
system too such as them being controlled
by the teachers unions and
indoctrination that's happening in the
schools as well uh and just having a
one-size-fits-all system that doesn't uh
will never meet the individual needs of
families who disagree about how they
want their kids raised and I think
that's what we've seen a lot over the
past couple of years and we've seen some
pushes from the top down to control the
curriculum from one side and we've seen
other reformers such as myself pushing
from the bottom up to create more um of
a thousand flowers blooming approach a
free market approach let's talk about
that in a second I want to uh add
um let's see if I can get this working
here okay so
um I just happened to be as I was
reading your book I happen to be reading
a book called Great Expectations which
is a study of the baby boom uh
generation that was published in 1980
and just as a kind of backdrop
um this uh in leading into uh the uh a
nation at risk one of the big concerns
was that
um test scores had been going down for
almost the entirety of the baby boom so
um you know that's part of what you know
when a nation at risk came out it was
addressing how crappy public schools had
gotten or education in general and these
are just SAT scores for college-bound
seniors
um in 1963 68 73 and 78 so kind of the
years before that and you see declines
consistently through that more recently
um because I want to get to you know
that's 40 years ago
um the SAT of course uh and if you
either are younger or you have kids of
uh you know High School age or whatever
you know that the SAT
um gets changed every once in a while it
gets re-centered and since 2017 uh the
old uh quantitative and verb and verbal
sections had been supplemented by a
critical uh or rather a writing section
those have been merged again and these
are the most recent scores which have
been going down but basically what we're
looking at if you take a nation of risk
and mediocrity we're essentially looking
at 80 years of kind of uh collapse so
um and I guess the other thing that I
wanted to just talk about as a as a kind
of stage uh as a uh scenes setter
um is as Corey you were talking about in
the 80s in particular particularly under
people I think like uh William Bennett
uh Secretary of Education there was a a
desire for standardized testing to kind
of show what was going on and uh there
seemed also to be an emphasis on the
idea of a curriculum that would kind of
fit everybody that the gov that the
country should be aspiring to
um as opposed to this kind of
individualized personalized
um you know approach that seems to be
more what contemporary school choice
Advocates are talking about and I guess
Connor let me uh go to you just to uh
ask you know in the 90s uh is when the
idea of charter schools
um became you know a policy priority
um and can you talk a little bit about
charter schools and how that push kind
of reflects a desire less for one type
of curriculum that we all know is the
best and will work all the time and work
for everybody and getting more into kind
of dispersing or decentralizing uh
educational curricula
well the the push for Charter Schools as
you point out in the 90s I think uh is
best contextualized as coming on the
coattails of the reforms in the 80s with
homeschooling homeschooling was was
effectively illegal in Most states until
a lot of Court battles throughout the
80s that really sparked a wave of kind
of parental rights and educational
reform and uh interest in saying hey we
need Alternatives there had been a large
underground homeschooling uh movement of
course but this was kind of brought
above board in part with the support of
groups like The Homeschool legal defense
Association that went and fought and
knocked down a lot of these state laws
leading leading us to the 90s as you
point out with the charter school
movement this idea that rather than a
one-size-fits-all approach rather than
you know we do it this way in this
school and here's the conveyor belt what
if we could create some flexibility
within the system they weren't
questioning the system overall they
weren't saying let's have education's
you know savings accounts or vouchers or
whatever but hey could we have school
that look a little bit differently that
operate a little bit differently I'm
ultimately not a big fan of charter
schools just because I I don't think
that they've lived up to the vision of
their original proponents a lot of times
they devolve into kind of lipstick on a
pig in the sense that they have
superficial differences and and some
marginal differences but fundamentally
they're all following the same
curriculum standards and required to do
things largely the same way that happens
in the public schools but you can do you
can certainly see in the early stages of
those battles again on the coattails of
the homeschooling reforms and increased
desire which now is is substantially
larger for parents to say we need
something different because the status
quo isn't working yeah let's um look at
um
a slide here if I I apologize for my
technical uh difficulties
um
[Music]
here we go okay so uh just to uh kind of
talk a little bit more about backdrop as
well uh Corey this is a piece that you
wrote in 2020 inflation-adjusted K-12
education spending per student has
increased by 280 percent since 1960.
um
you know so uh on average the U.S spends
over 15 grand a year per student
um where has that money gone because
that you know and this is inflation
adjusted so it's you know it's not
simply because everything is more
expensive than in 1960. what are what
are the main components of per pupil
spending
yeah look and that is from June of 2020
um so that the spending is a lot higher
now even than it was in 2020 because of
all the so-called coveted relief I think
we've pumped 190 billion dollars in in
so-called coveted relief into the K-12
School System since March of 2020 which
is over three or four thousand dollars
per student so we spend a lot more now
than we did then and even then if you
just look between 1970 and
um 2019 with the latest Federal data
that we have nationwide uh per student
with increased pers per student
education expenditures by uh 152 percent
over that period and teacher salaries
since 1970 have increased only by about
eight percent so it's not going towards
the teachers in the classroom it's going
more towards Staffing surges and
administrative blow if you look at a
report by Ben scaffidy back to the
Staffing surge he looks at different
periods of time finding that uh the the
number of support staff in particular re
raises exponentially in in different
locations whereas student enrollment and
teachers in this in the buildings is
pretty stagnant and I think that's
because the current school system is a
one-size-fits-all monopoly that has no
incentive to spend additional dollars
wisely so they put it towards more
people because more employees means more
dues paying members for the the teachers
unions which means more money for people
like Randy Weingarten who make over five
hundred thousand dollars a year so even
even uh but it's not even going to
teachers it's going to staff who then
end up joining unions
that's right and if you look between uh
there's a been a image that goes around
on Twitter pretty pretty uh often that I
was the first one to create it I didn't
put my name on it I probably should have
but it's a graph between
2000 and 2019 using Federal data sources
finding that the number of students in
the system increased by about seven
percent the number of teachers in the
system similar about seven or eight
percent but then the number of
administrative staff increased by about
80 percent so looking at different
periods we find the same uh what are
what are those people doing what are
what are the support staff what are the
non-instructional staff doing
well they uh a whole host of different
things
um so in Los Angeles for example uh
since 2019 they had a plan to of what to
do with the additional 69 percent of
spending that was going into the Los
Angeles Public Schools and the latest uh
report that I saw showed a an increase
of counselors by about uh 80 percent and
an increase in in teaching staff by much
lower lower number while student
enrollment over the same period was
projected to decrease by about six
percent so in what other industry do you
lose your customers lose six percent of
your customers and then start hiring
more and more people with Los Angeles
Public Schools now spending uh in the
latest budget I believe over twenty five
thousand dollars per student so they're
just a whole host of different you know
they're trying to make the schools
um and they can they can they can lay
out arguments as to why it might be a
good idea to have more counselors
because while we closed the schools and
we heard the kids mentally so now we've
got to fix the problems that we created
by hiring more counselors yeah and so
they just
um yeah they'll throw everything at the
wall see what sticks and and hire as
many people as they can in any position
yeah go ahead Connor I was just going to
add briefly and tie us back to your uh
slide with the SAT scores what's
especially compelling about the data
that Corey is describing is that if you
look at the test scores across the same
period of time whatever chunks of time
you want to look at the test scores are
flat now Corey and I you know are we
don't believe that standardized testing
is the you know some bonum of
educational attainment but it is an
effective way to try and at least assess
lightly uh what the performance looks
like and test scores have not gone up so
the the increases in investment in the
administrative class of these schools
may have its perks may have its uh
stated purposes but it's not trickling
down to improving the education of the
students and that I think is what's most
compelling about the problem is that uh
we're we're chasing uh you know putting
bad money into a system that isn't
ultimately serving the ideal uh customer
for which it purportedly exists and so
we say we say in the book ultimately
that why do schools exist now it's not
to educate students it's a jobs program
for adults and the Union's defending
that is ultimately its core value
proposition at this point so let me uh
throw up another slide here because I
you know this is to me I mean one of you
know the most stunning cases for school
reform is simply whether it's 1960 or
1970 you know wherever you want to start
the clock running
expenses per student are way way up and
test scores as you're saying they're
flat in some cases slightly declining in
some cases slightly up and regardless of
whether you know we think oh the the
only thing that matters is how people do
uncenteredized tests
um you know that's like it's it's
clearly like unless we just want to say
kids are Dumber now there's something
wrong when you're spending so much more
money to get the same result you got you
know 20 or 50 years ago or 60 years ago
and yet and I guess this moves into our
next phase when you look at parental
satisfaction
um of schools this is kind of
mind-boggling to me and I'm wondering um
you know if you guys could comment on
this a little bit this is satisfaction
rights
um for you know if you have a kid
attending school whether you're very
satisfied satisfied dissatisfied very
dissatisfied and and this charts you
know private school Parents Choice
District parents so that's people who
are in a district that offers Choice
whether or not you uh take advantage of
it assigned District school parents so
that's people whose kids just go to a
traditional residential assignment
schools wherever the district says your
kid's going here you go with that or
Charter School parents who have some and
what's amazing is when you look at the
red numbers there's not as much variance
as you would expect right like wouldn't
I and I guess my question for you and um
uh Corey why don't you start you know
why aren't if schools are spending so
much money and doing such a mediocre job
why aren't parents you know Burning Down
the schools
well this doesn't capture all the
parents who are pushing back at the
school board meetings who are
dissatisfied with their schools so
um yeah this is one of the polls but
there's also another one from I believe
Pew research finding that support among
the public school system among
Republicans is at an all-time low I
believe it was Pew research so you know
there's other polls but you know who
what are you going to believe this uh
this graphic or or My Lying Eyes
um yeah I don't know
yeah I think things have changed over
time as well especially more recently
with the school closures and parents
getting to see another dimension of
school quality that's more important
than test scores like a lot of families
might have had their kids in a rated
schools and thought hey my school's good
there's nothing there's not a problem
with my kids school but now that they've
seen something else going on where well
maybe they're they're not just focusing
on academics they're focusing on these
other things that I disagree with and I
think that's also why we've seen a more
recent Surge and support for school
choice because family started to see
that school quality is multi-dimensional
and their kids are not being raised in
ways that are aligned with their values
yeah I mean I know uh uh Corey you and I
have talked about this at various points
over the years that you know the covet
experience if if the Vietnam War was the
living room War because it was the first
war that you know was shown on in
people's television you know in in their
family rooms their living rooms like it
was in the house covid was somewhat
analogous in that people parents started
to see what their kids were actually
learning during the day uh you know
because of Zoom classes and things like
that which were you know clearly a
catastrophe for everybody on every level
involved and you know there's no
question that poor uh or low-income uh
students in low-income households
suffered worse but if you know nobody
was happy with that and it's kind of
like if this is what I'm paying for I'm
going to be kind of pissed and and one
other thing there's a lot of polls that
we've shown over time even before covid
and the closures uh and Ed Choice does a
lot of these and I know there's other
groups that do these polls as well but
Nationwide just asking a different
question where do you send your kid and
where would you send your kid if money
weren't an issue and overwhelmingly
those polls typically find that again
you know 9 90 percent of kids are in
public schools but if they had a real
choice to make it more economically
feasible to send them to a private or
religious or Charter or or home school
option only about half of that amount
respond that they would still have their
kid in the public school so I think
that's more of a revealing statistic
um Conor uh to uh you had mentioned
earlier that um let me uh
sorry about this uh doing a uh
sorry I am not as uh technically Adept
as I uh
yes uh
if you could uh
we don't want that
I want to uh bring Connor into the main
frame uh thank you
um uh Connor you you suggested I mean
you're not enamored of charter schools
because they're essentially a version of
uh Public Schools I mean they're you
know lipstick on a pig
um in many ways private schools are like
that as well I mean that or you know
that they I mean most schools tend to do
something similar
um you know and they do it better or
worse and that's partly dependent on the
the facility it's partly dependent on
the faculty of a school it's also partly
dependent on the the family of the kids
who are going
um a lot of educational achievement it
tracks with parental education levels
and and socioeconomic status and things
like that
um Jess has a that's a backdrop to the
question of
um you know what what does what is the
education for what is K-12 education for
in your model
um what you know because I think part of
uh when I think about school reform and
about the impediments to it part of it
is that we assume that what what
education is for is to create kids who
know a lot and are good thinkers and are
critical thinkers and know a bit about
the past uh something about the future
and then have the skills to kind of
create learning going forward but what
if you know from a kind of quasi-public
choice libertarian or Marxist angle what
if the function of Education it really
has very little to do with you know
giving your kids you know skills or
knowledge and it's more to just kind of
replicate or continue the status quo
um
you know can you speak to that and then
kind of lay out what what is your vision
of what K-12 education should be
aspiring to do sure it's a provocative
set of questions
um I think the answers depend on on the
content so do we want to look at this
through the lens of The Architects of
the modern public education system what
their purposes and intent were were they
really trying to create critical
thinkers independent minded rugged
individualists who you know in a Iran
fashion uh had self-ownership and and
congrationally think and build a Freer
future well no quite the opposite when
you look at Horace Mann and John Dewey
and All These Guys these were secular
humanist socialists they were
collectivists fundamentally they
literally talked openly and frequently
about how they wanted to socially
engineer the rising generation to better
conform to their Vision future and so
that's why when we hear parents saying
oh the school system's broken we say
well is it because if you go back to its
early Architects a lot of what we see
today and there's kind of a right-wing
version of that too right did the uh you
know and I'm thinking my parents were
born in the 20s they were the children
of immigrants so they needed to be
Americanized sure and they were yeah one
of them went to a Catholic school during
the Depression in New York the other
went to a public school they weren't
being taught to be independent thinkers
they were being taught on some level to
be good Americans and that meant you
know they could say the Pledge of
Allegiance but also that they would be
good workers that they would show up and
follow orders and be more or less
productive right so there's a kind of
National Association of Manufacturers
version of what education is for as well
there very much is there's this kind of
uh economic overlay over the system
where for a century plus it's been
perceived that it's a feeding system a
feeder into the economy which is why
what we call today Public Schools Corey
and I use the term government schools in
the book because we think that's more
accurate but they used to be called
Factory schools for a long time they
were literally called Factory schools
why they were trained training kids to
sit at a desk follow orders do their
little task be a cog in a machine raise
their hand if they need another bathroom
and it was widely perceived in a very
positive way that this was going to help
prepare kids for having good jobs we see
this today even though we have a totally
different economy though we have the
same education system from a century ago
that was for a different economy but we
see it today with things like Common
Core and No Child Left Behind and other
emphases that are focusing on what are
called College and Career Readiness so
the purported purpose today of the K-12
system is to basically prepare children
for higher education and for uh for the
economy what's fascinating I
unfortunately don't recall off the top
of my head who did the poll we cite it
in the book but just a few months ago
this huge poll came out and they did a
really interesting uh had an interesting
methodology they were asking parents
their own perspective of how they
prioritize is K-12 education in other
words why do you think K-12 education is
important for your child but then they
also ask them how they perceive others
uh rank that type of perception so
College and Career Readiness right
parents for their own children
prioritize that very low on the spectrum
of priorities they they de-emphasize
that they didn't think it was that
important however when they were asked
what they perceived society and their
peers prioritize it it was very high
because everyone thinks that that's why
we educate kids that's why we put them
through all the misery of you know all
these years of schooling is so that
they'll have a good job is so that
they'll be prepared for the future what
ranked at the top for parents uh two
things practical skill development not
these abstract ideas of you know getting
you ready for a future career but very
practical skills financial management
and everything else and number two is
critical thinking and uh and if you were
to assess the modern education system
based on those things I think it ranks
very poorly uh your final question yeah
so what yeah what what for you what is
the vision of you know what what is what
is uh you know education for in two
minutes or less here we go okay so
um you know the root word of Education
when you look at the etymology it is to
draw out uh the modern school system is
trying to fill and cram kids full of
knowledge just in case they ever need it
30 years from now and need to remember
that the mitochondrion is the PowerHouse
of the cell
um I I think by contrast true education
is trying to draw out it is a Socratic
method it is trying to challenge uh kids
and adults to think critically about
their own ideas to identify where they
can find that information from so I
think what we ultimately need is
educational entrepreneurship is why I'm
so bullish on micro schools because what
you're finding is a lot of teachers who
are fed up with the bureaucracy they
make way more money and have total
freedom starting their own school and
then they can Cobble together curriculum
and activities and projects from a
variety of sources my own kids go to an
actin Academy I'm a huge fan of acting
academies they're all over the country
can you explain what that is yeah yeah
they're kind of a montessori-like
private school uh typically they're
micro schools these are small schools
but they're very Socratic in nature it's
project-based learning it's self-guided
the there are no teachers the kids are
in charge of their own education the
adults are what are called guides so
they're there to help when needed but
they provide all these resources to kids
they provide them the time and the
educational freedom to follow their
Curiosities and figure out what they
want to do they have a peer Community
there to kind of debate and challenge
ideas and work together on projects and
it provides the children not only a lot
more self-ownership to direct their own
education but the freedom to do so the
the biggest thing that we stifled for
kids that was stifled for me as a
graduate of what I call the public
school system was that I had no
education freedom I I would be curious
about things I would raise my hand hey
why you know are you learning this oh
put your hand down it'll be on the test
so fundamentally Corey mentioned this
earlier it's a pseudo-monopoly
fundamentally what I believe the school
system needs is competition we know that
that's how things improve and prices go
down I'm not so uh I'm not a central
planner I'm not going to say we should
re-architect all of K-12 education based
on this I think though systematically
what we need is to introduce competition
to the system and unleash education
entrepreneurship to find a diversity of
approaches and curricula and options
that can best resonate with each unique
individual experience we don't really
have that we have a small amount but
with all these states passing education
savings accounts and other reforms I
think I'm increasingly hopeful about the
future that we're going to have more of
a Marketplace of educational approaches
to to help kids in the future I you know
one of the things as you were talking
um it was fascinating to me you know we
talk about horseshoes area you know on
the right and the left of how extremes
come together in a way many of the the
kind of pedagogical uh you know kind of
orientation that you were talking about
reminded me of Paola Ferreira the uh you
know the the Marxist Brazilian uh kind
of bet Noir of a lot of right-wing
conservatives because he opposed what he
called the banking theory of Education
that you know you put kids in a
classroom and then you fill them with
information you're depositing knowledge
and whatnot and his whole idea from a
hard left position was that now we need
to be creating kids who are critical
thinkers who will interrogate the
structures of the society that of which
they're apart
um that's kind of fascinating I guess
Corey does um you know how does this the
version of things that you guys are
talking about is radically dispersed
radically decentralized highly
individualized how does that play uh
among kind of right-wing School
reformers who oftentimes seem to be
talking about we now you know there is
this one best way to teach things and we
know what that is and we need to kind of
be pushing that through the system yeah
I mean we've seen two different types of
reforms being pushed to fix the
curriculum disagreements in the
government school system and and one has
been from the top down to ban CRT for
example or other Concepts that are uh
divisive Concepts which one doesn't
actually work because it's a basically a
form of playing whack-a-mole where
you're trying to hit the mole then the
mold doesn't actually go down it doesn't
work it's unenforceable we have videos
from all these States from Texas from
Idaho from Tennessee from Iowa uh and
others where you have undercover
journalists going there from accuracy
and media and getting the public school
officials to admit that yeah we banned
it here but we'd still do it we just
call it social emotional learning or we
call it student mental health so they
just move the goal post and it's totally
unenforceable uh for the most part and
the better solution in in my view is
from the bottom up with school choice
it's like if you're just not going to
listen to what the law says anyway and
if it's really hard to if we can't even
agree on what critical race Theory even
means and it means different things to
different parents
um they parents know like the specific
things that they want and what they do
not want taught and the better way is to
just give the money to the parents in
the form of an education savings account
and let them choose the school that best
aligns with their values I think this is
the only way forward through Freedom as
opposed to force so that families can
choose the schools that that align with
their values and meet their needs in
other ways the whole government school
system is inherently in conflict with
our view of what education should look
like which is parents raising kids in
ways that that they want to you can't do
that what they one-size-fits all
government School Monopoly it is by
definition never going to work you're
always going to have one group of
parents forcing their views on another
group of parents it's typically a
majority or in some cases a special
interest minority inflicting their views
on other groups and that is a problem
and the only way out is is through
allowing parents to choose and and
things like what Conor was talking about
with microschools might be one of the
best ways I I find I mean I find that
Vision that sadly my kids are already uh
my younger son is about to graduate
college so it's it's all too late for
him but I find that Vision that you guys
are are kind of articulating of of a
radical uh dispersion of power and money
and of uh you know allowing a thousand
flowers to bloom in terms of curriculum
uh just you know really bracing and
exciting
um let's talk uh if we can have that
slide back up Bess
thank you um you know one of uh so uh
you know Connor I'm curious how do you
you your book uh you have a blurb from
Chris Ruffo the Manhattan Institute uh
uh scholar who has really kind of pushed
the uh the demonization of critical race
Theory and a variety of other kinds of
uh left-wing educational you know
priorities that he says are throughout
the K-12 system he also we've talked to
him on reason and elsewhere also says
he's a fan of uh school choice when we
and he's tight with uh Ron DeSantis uh
he was at the signing of uh one at least
one of the uh kind of education reform
bills that uh DeSantis did
DeSantis the governor of Florida leading
you know candidate possibly for the
Republican nomination for president is a
kind of fascinating case study Florida
has a robust school choice program that
he has been adding to it existed before
him but he has has added it but he's
also Going Hammer and tongue after
certain specific aspects not just with
the K-12 education but has also tried to
do that at the um at the college and or
post-secondary level how do you how do
you feel about somebody like a DeSantis
something similar I guess is going on in
a place like Texas uh with Greg Abbott
where Texas you know oddly has not been
a leader in school choice despite you
know being a conservative state but you
know what do you make of somebody like a
DeSantis is is this
um you know is this just an internal
contradiction that will have to explode
or you know what what do you what do you
have to say about somebody like a
DeSantis I think that the example Corey
used earlier of political whack-a-mole
is instructive here right when you're a
hammer everything looks like a nail when
you're a big you know Mallet everything
looks like a mole and a whack-a-mole
game and someone like the santis who is
seeking higher office and trying to uh
illustrate his kind of distinctions from
Trump and other candidates on the the
field uh is leaning into this moment
when as Corey pointed out a lot of these
parents are upset they're going to
school board meetings they're trying to
to fight back so I think it's
politically strategic on his part to be
kind of the tip of the spear in fighting
some of this through the political
process where others are just trying to
show up to school board meetings and
pressure elected officials he is one and
he has a bully pulpit and he can do
something about it
um you know Chris has done yeoman's work
with CRT and other issues trying to
raise the warning voice trying to make
clear that these are problems
fundamentally that's the purpose of the
book that Corey and I have out is to be
a warning voice and say Here's all these
problems happening but at the end of the
day uh what DeSantis is doing and other
efforts like this through the political
process to uh to restrict teachers to
modify curriculum to tie the hands of
local Educators and the teachers unions
uh number one it's only going to go so
far as Corey pointed out they're going
to wiggle around it and find a way
around it so it looks good superficially
for DeSantis to enact these controls or
others like him but when the rubber
meets the road are we really having the
substantive changes that were you know
purported to happen when the law was
passed or the executive order was signed
fundamentally I think of the Henry David
Thoreau quote that there are for every
thousand hacking at the at the branches
there's only one striking at the root
and we've been here before we've been
here with common core we've been here
with social emotional learning we've
been here at critical race Theory and
now all this you know gender Wars and
many other things in the decades
preceding the examples I listed and
where has that gotten us where have the
substantive reform spent nothing is
going to happen until we strike the root
the root as I perceive it and I think
Corey agrees is the Monopoly is the
guaranteed uh consumer pipeline to the
government school system and until we
introduced substantial competitive
forces to induce enough market pressure
on these institutions to reform none of
these topical marginal uh efforts are
going to have substantive change they
might make us feel good in the moment
we'll all applaud at a press conference
when the new reform is announced but you
know months later when the dust settles
and people's attention moves on to the
next topic and everyone forgets about it
all the people who are still there all
the teachers union members all the
administrators are going to be
continuing to do what they want to do
and and we're just going to further
slide into mediocrity so we
fundamentally need competition and
that's why the school Choice Movement I
think is exploding is because so many
parents as you point out Nick with zoom
school and uh during kovitz so many more
parents have an appetite now for
Alternatives
yeah go ahead teachers union know is
that school choice is the bigger threat
to their Monopoly than these top-down
reforms if you look at some elections
for example in in Georgia uh it was an
interesting general election for their
superintendent these the Republican was
against CRT and and was for CRT bands
but was against school choice and the
Democrat was actually for uh school
choice
um and so the teachers union uh did not
endorse the Democrat in that race I
believe they endorsed the Republican
instead despite his opposition to CRT
and that just goes to show you they're
more afraid of bottom-up reform because
that actually threatens their power so
um you guys are both proponents of
educational savings or education savings
accounts which would divert a fair
amount of uh not all but a fair amount
of school funding typically at the state
level
to directly to parents to use kind of
however they see fit uh in order to
increase the education or direct the
education of their kids Arizona is
really kind of Blazing a trail there as
well as a couple of other places let me
ask for you know if we're talking about
you know giving parents seven thousand
dollars nine thousand dollars ten
thousand dollars you know not not the
full average amount of per-pupil
spending but uh essentially a voucher to
uh use towards whatever kind of
educational experiences you want to pay
for for your kids and Connor why don't
you go first what are the limits on that
um you know if it's tax funded money
it's going you know it is going directly
to the parents so in that sense it's
like a Pell Grant and I don't think we
need to worry or get into questions of
whether or not Senate using that send
your kid to a religious school is a
problem it shouldn't be any more than it
is to use a Pell Grant to go to a
religious college but are there limits
um what we should uh you know we should
expect tax dollars to fund when it comes
to education for K-12 students
uh so I run a thing tank in Utah
libertas Institute and 15 years ago in
uh in Utah we were leaders in the school
choice movement and passing a Innovative
voucher law uh into place it would give
each child each student about three to
four thousand dollars but as with a
typical voucher program that money would
entirely go to a private school of the
family's choosing so the the funding was
flowing directly to the institution
creating a Nexus for uh potential and
likely regulation so I was never really
a fan of the the voucher model uh of
course the teachers unions were far less
of a fan they the Nea invested two
million dollars to overturn that Utah
law because they saw that this would
kind of trickle down and go elsewhere
they were successful in overturning it
and so until this year when we passed a
universal Esa program in Utah there
hadn't really been school choice because
everyone was terrified of the teachers
unions until this postcoded moment where
you know parental interest in Choice has
has skyrocketed and so I think this is
kind of the moment that we're in where
the political landscape is changing and
so many more people are demanding uh
reforms which is why you see a lot uh
more esa's passing and I think it is
structurally a better little for the
reason you're asking in that the money
is going to the family and they could
spend a little bit on Amazon a little
bit on the museum for a field trip a
little bit on you know Tuttle twins
books for example a lot of families do
and what you see a kind of a
decentralization of the finances which
means that that regulatory Nexus that
the the Temptation for bureaucrats to
attach the strings is severely weakened
I'm not going to say it's eliminated
because you know enterprising
bureaucrats do what they do but
um as we were working on our own Utah
really putting in a lot of intentional
language to tie the hands of bureaucrats
to really impede their ability to step
in and try to
I guess my one of my questions is you
know uh on food stamps or in SNAP
benefits you know you can buy you know
uh uh I don't know you know you can't
buy cigarettes and whiskey right with
with SNAP benefits
um you can't buy certain types of food
certain types of candy and things like
that is there are there limits I guess
what I'm asking is like in an Esa
um you know
should uh you know your consent you can
spend the money on Amazon books but not
on all books or like and and I'm not
asking I I guess what I'm asking is
conceptually not politically are there
limits like how do we you know how do we
know that this isn't just going to the
parents car or something yeah that's
okay that's a great question and I'm
glad you gave it a little bit more Focus
so this is going to depend state to
state and how they structure their laws
but the answer is is yes there are
limits and typically what states are
doing what we did in Utah is there will
be a select a range of pre-approved
materials courses programs curriculum
and so forth that the administrators
have pre-vetted and so that makes easy
but then you can also then request
one-off approvals and say hey we're
interested in doing this we just need
someone to acknowledge that that works
fundamentally this treats these expenses
more as an auditable thing rather than a
regulatory thing in the sense that
you're not going to have Regulators like
with food stamps no one steps in says
I'm going to tell you how to raise your
children now that you're you know
getting food stamps apps if anything
it's just a simple audit process to see
if the expenses were authorized or not
and so Most states have a predetermined
set of expenses that are qualified in
the statute to give guidance then to the
regulators and administrators to say
anything falling under this umbrella and
most of those umbrellas are fairly broad
so yes it could be books on Amazon as
long as you can substantiate that
there's an educational benefit for the
students using them the devil's in the
details but most programs that I've seen
and certainly ours in Utah is written
broadly enough that parents will be able
to fairly easily justify things that
actually have an educational benefit to
there
but well or maybe right I mean or but
the the default setting is the default
setting is you know uh you know the
parents unless something really raises a
red flag we're not going to worry about
it it strikes me and I a fundamental
difference with a section 529 plan which
is the you know tax advantage savings
for college but you can pretty much
spend your section 529 money on anything
related to your kid you might get
audited but it's kind of loose that way
um obviously it's different because it's
your money although you know you get a
tax break on it but
um yeah that I mean it's it's
interesting because I guess part of it
is the politics of selling school choice
um you know who who are the main
constituents I mean there is there's a
reformer class and you guys are
exemplars of this
um they're you know but then who else
what what kinds of parents are calling
for a radical Choice uh agenda
Connor yeah
it's all I mean it's all sorts of
parents you have uh homeschoolers who
might want to use this for homeschooling
expenses or micro schoolers it could be
families uh who want to send their kids
to private school to pay for tuition and
fees it could be families who are in uh
failing government schools I mean you
look at a lot of the up and the the
programs that have been running for
years and the average income of the
Florida tax credit scholarship program
for example uh before they expanded it
uh this this past year was about forty
thousand dollars uh per household in DC
uh where I'm actually at right now in
the hotel but
um their voucher program that started in
I want to say 2003 or 2005. their
average household income for that
program is about uh thirty thousand
dollars per household and uh so these
are low income
highly motivated what about having
special needs families too uh what about
religious I mean religious people are
definitely interested in this a lot
right because they often have most the
most beef with uh kind of public school
agenda what about in the suburbs because
you know a plurality of Americans live
in Suburban settings
um you know school districts and I mean
this is spurious but it's deeply deeply
held that the quality of your schools uh
reflect very much in the value of your
house
um and you move to a uh you know if you
have kids you move to a town with good
schools which generally means it's a
little bit more you know a higher income
or if you don't have kids and most
people don't have kids right most
households don't have K-12 students uh
they don't want to do anything that's
going to mess up the property values
right
um how do you how do you address that
and you know how do you activate people
like that well if you like your public
school you can keep your public school
unlike with your doctor it's actually
true and when school choice is expanded
the public schools if anything get
better because of competition so right
and there is actually a lot of research
to should suggest I mean going back
decades that whether it's Catholic
schools or Charter Schools or whatever
the you know when there's more types of
schools the public schools actually the
traditional Public Schools up their game
but yeah it's a rising tide that lifts
all boats 26 to 29 of the studies on the
topic are are positive so overwhelmingly
positive evidence on that so school
choice doesn't destroy the public
schools it makes them better and in fact
during the pandemic period Michael
hartney and Leslie finger did a study
that's peer reviewed now finding that in
places that had more Catholic schools
nearby which were open over the pandem
for the most part
um the public schools are more likely to
open too in person so that suggested a
competitive effect too even during uh
the covered era even when it just came
to whether you opened your opened your
school or not
um so this is why Defenders of the
status quo the teachers unions they try
to label people like Connor and I as as
as those who want to destroy the public
school system because they know some
people they like their Public Schools
um but a lot of those people who did
like their Public Schools pre-pandemic
who thought that they had they bought
themselves into a fantastic Public
School District because of the rating by
the state
started to see there's something else
going on here too so um that story is a
little bit yeah let me add a quick
exclamation point on that so going back
to the polling data you shared about the
high satisfaction rate that parents have
um I think you know tying that to what
Corey is saying uh my my perspective is
that the existing system is being
destroyed that we are dumbing down our
education that we are sliding as a
society into intellectual mediocrity all
the while parents are quote unquote
satisfied it's kind of like the frog and
the the proverbial pot of boiling water
right so many of these families I would
argue don't realize the depth and the
breadth of the problem they think well I
went to public school I turned out fine
so you know I like my kids teachers and
the football team is great what does it
mean to be satisfied right so when you
ask as Corey point out when he asked the
question a different way when you you
know do things differently you get
different results but I do feel like the
Ardent Defenders of the status quo are
the ones actually try trying to protect
the subtle and slow destruction of the
education system and so they malign
people like Corey and I who are out
there trying to push some competition
against them and improve the quality
they claim that we're the ones
destroying it when fundamentally we're
actually trying to increase and improve
educational attainment recognizing that
the status quo is is quite the opposite
and one more thing on that on that chart
is that people don't like to admit that
they're sending their kid to an
institution that is failing their child
for 13 years so if you give everybody
options even if they don't have them
today if you provide that option in the
form of an education savings account I
feel like those numbers would change as
well we're looking at kind of a static
model as opposed to a dynamic model if
there was true Choice then people would
be more likely to to say that maybe I
want that choice too
I want to introduce a quote from Robert
pandicio who said uh AEI as they wrote
this for the uh Fordham Institute but
it's provocative and I want to get your
uh your reaction to this uh pandisio who
we had a uh uh back during school choice
week Zach was real and I talked to him
for a lively hour
one of his critiques and he's taught he
taught in the South Bronx in a
low-income uh educationally uh
challenged uh school and one of his big
things is that you know we're not
teaching basic reading and everything
kind of flows from that he's both an
advocate an absolute advocate of school
choice but also believes in certain kind
of core pedagogical conceits as well but
he writes there is an idea especially
prevalent among Libertarians and some
conservatives that school choice is the
answer to the problems of social justice
activism and political indoctrination in
schools because it allows parents to
pull their children out of schools where
woke ideology has infused the curriculum
and school culture the idea is not just
wrong or simplistic it's dangerous
um my question because you've touched on
this about how
um you know a lot of uh you know the
attempts of some of this stuff are is
whack-a-mole but I guess my question uh
for you guys is
um
the issue of
um kind of community one of the things
that seems to be you know a front and
center concern in contemporary America
is the idea that
um for a variety of reasons and some
people paint this more positively some
more negatively but we are able to
individualize our life experience more
um you know across a wide variety of
boundaries uh certainly in the 90s and
early 2000s at reason we celebrated the
mass individualization and the mass
personalization of culture of lifestyle
of economic service and you know and
Matt Welch my colleague and I wrote a
book called The Declaration of
Independence where he said you know like
the places where this aren't isn't
happening are places like education
retirement and and health care because
they're overwhelmingly dominated by
governments at various levels but I
guess my question with that pandisio
quote where where does common culture go
in this debate because it seems like
America is desperate for some kind of
commonality but school choice which I
certainly support exactly in the way you
guys are talking about it would lead in
a different direction more of a of a
kind of uh vulcanized experience
yeah go ahead yeah
so we don't have we don't have it we
have nine out of ten kids in public
schools today and we have a extremely
divided uh country today and politically
polarized country so the you know
there's kind of this fairy tale
um theory of the democratic Pro public
yeah the public schools were The
Crucible uh yeah I mean Milton Friedman
used to talk about this it was a product
of public schools in the 1920s and 30s
and he would often talk about that uh
that goes back to that a kind of
Americanization model which may or may
not have worked um yeah but it certainly
is not where we're at now I don't think
it works when you have a monopolistic
school system and you know who gets to
decide what that common culture is going
to look like it's typically a a certain
group and what we've seen how the
political process works is usually a
minority special interests inflicting
their views on other people's kids and
uh we have a ton of evidence on this in
the school choice literature as well I
did one of them uh peer-reviewed review
of The Evidence called do
self-interested schooling selections
um improve Society or whatever I called
the type whatever it was and Patrick
Wolfe at University of Arkansas did one
called Civics exam and education next
and finding and also in my my co-edited
book with Neil McCluskey from Cato
Institute Patrick Wolff updated his his
uh meta-analysis of this literature in
one of the chapters in that book and
overwhelmingly the studies find that
private school choice in particular
leads to more better Civic outcomes
including tolerance of others views
which I think is a really important one
more political participation uh and
other Civic outcomes as well so the
evidence doesn't bear out the theories
that are laid out by the the government
School Defenders yeah
yeah so I I recently had the opportunity
to go back to my old stomping grounds
where I went to high school I grew up in
San Diego and uh and I went to the high
school and it was a very sad experience
what before was an open set of uh
buildings and free-flowing student body
was under lock and key there were Gates
everywhere cameras metal detectors and
all the rest and that school is not an
anomaly especially with all the school
shootings so many people want to further
turn these into prison-like institutions
so to your question about community and
culture I question whether a statist
institution such as Government schools
is really going to enhance our community
build community enhance the culture
build the social fabric I think quite
the opposite I think the state is on one
end of the spectrum and true Society is
on the other we need voluntary
relationships and so forth to be able to
rebuild that and as a long time
homeschooling dad I only put my kids in
that micro school this past fall we've
been homeschooling them for a decade and
of course early on we would get the
critiques like you sometimes hear oh
your kids aren't going to be socialized
they're you know they're not going to be
part of the community and then I look at
what how kids on on you know with all
the book like on in the government
schools The Bullying the talks City
pornography drugs cheating and all the
rest and I'm like that's not how I want
my kids to be socialized when my kids
are out doing field trips in the middle
of the day while all their public school
peers are sitting in a box in a brick
and mortar cage my kids are out there
connecting with adults shopping at
businesses going through museums
connecting with other families there's
very strong community and I think that
through this kind of decentralized
educational Marketplace if we can
continue to grow and sustain it we're
going to have a far richer and more
tightly interwoven social fabric of true
Community than we do right now with
everyone just sitting in these Factory
schools across the country being
propagandized by leftist public school
teachers yeah if I may uh I went to uh
Catholic grammar school in high school
in Middletown New Jersey at my high
school
which is an indicator of how bad it was
despite being you know private Catholic
it was parochial school actually went
out of business a couple years ago and
for me that was uh you know that was a
happy day to know that you know children
were were no longer going to be uh
softly imprisoned in that particular
space another moment of kind of
horseshoe theory of uh you know uh
people like Michelle Foucault who I you
know is not in good uh standing among uh
many uh uh among um many uh uh right
wing School reformers but he often
likened as the people like Thomas saws
you know mandatory schooling is a kind
of minimum security prison
um so it's it's very interesting to hear
you uh discuss it in those terms Connor
and certainly the lockdowns uh you know
and the intensification of kind of
literal gatekeeping on School uh grounds
for you know a variety of mostly over
hyped but understandable concerns is
kind of fascinating I want to um we're
going to to wrap up we're going to uh
I'm going to ask you to talk about the
uh kind of of Direction and velocity of
school choice but before we do that I'd
like I'd like to just do a short kind of
biographical moment with each of you
Corey
um talk a little bit about your current
position and also your uh you have a PhD
in
um education can you talk a little bit
about you know what you're doing now and
how you got there
yeah I really got into this as a
researcher I did my PhD at the
University of Arkansas in their
Department of Education reform and my
first study linked the Milwaukee
parental Choice program which started in
1990 to by the way if I I'm sorry to
enter uh interrupt on that there's a
fantastic a couple of stories and
interviews with Polly Williams one of
the uh backwards of that estate
legislator in Milwaukee who and again to
show just this fascinating fascinating
kind of crossing of political wires had
been a member of the Black Panther Party
uh in the 60s and 70s and then helped
usher in you know the really the first I
believe it was the first uh publicly
funded uh voucher program in at least in
a major city but yeah and we get some
Democrats along with us today too it's
not as many as we would like in Nebraska
they had three co-sponsors on their bill
this year giving us the filibuster proof
majority uh it's they're about to pass
their their bill for the third time
um uh but but yeah so I I started by
looking at student level data from the
Milwaukee program with Patrick Wolfe at
University of Arkansas we found huge
reductions in the likelihood of crime in
Wisconsin if you have first name last
name and date of birth you can look up
anybody's criminal records which as a
Libertarian I didn't like that idea very
much but as a researcher it was great
because everybody else is looking at
test scores we're looking at really
important lifelong outcomes and since
then uh there have been six studies on
the topic all peer-reviewed I've done
two of them finding School more school
choice uh less crime later on in life
um and then so I kind of thought about
going into Academia for a while then I
started to realize that my peers in the
peer review process were my enemies not
so much my friends or my peers
um and although uh fighting that uphill
battle I've I've published over 30 or 40
peer-reviewed uh Journal articles uh and
just you know a handful of years
um so I've done a lot of work in in the
academic space but then also I started
to realize that I'm spending all this
time writing 50 60 page articles and
nobody's really reading them some of
them you make a big splash with like the
crime study and people uh want to learn
about that but
um I started to figure out I could have
more of an impact uh in other ways and
so I start went through the think tank
route where my first Think Tank role was
at the Cato Institute where I'd be
rewarded for my ID ideas as opposed to
being punished in the University system
where uh you know people didn't like I
had one peer reviewer on that that
Milwaukee study for example saying that
I I believe it's causal I believe I I I
I get it with the the methods are legit
but why are you asking this question you
are problematizing the situation by
saying that even asking that school
choice could reduce crime so it's just
it was a total disaster and so now I'm
at the American Federation for children
I'm a senior fellow I do a lot of
communications work but I do still I do
studies from time to time as well my
most recent one being during the
pandemic period with Christos mccready's
we found that places that had stronger
teachers unions were more likely to keep
the schools closed longer for for us
that was kind of a no-brainer finding
but it was good to put it down on paper
and write about it all right and of
course you did a stint at uh reason
Foundation as well but
um thank you for that and Connor uh talk
a little bit about the libertas
Institute as well as the Tuttle twins
series
so I come from more of a activist
background I hated school and it took me
a while to learn to love learning and
once I did I started you know binge
reading and and
self-teaching a lot of what I now do
started libertas Institute in 2011 as a
state-based think tank in Utah my new
adopted State since then we've expanded
our work across the country to work on
policies and gosh two dozen plus States
so far we've changed over 100 laws on a
wide range of topics civil forfeiture
drug policy property rights criminal
justice reform education policy and more
so we're more kind of the less of a
think tank perhaps a traditional Think
Tank more of a do tank I was hoping you
wouldn't say that that's one of you know
that's kind of like a trigger for me the
dude tank versus the think tank I even
hate that term I'm trying to come up
with a better term for It Go tank I
don't know drunk tank my point was that
while Corey and others can dig in and do
the research we'll leverage and work
with people like that and then we'll
we'll be kind of the boots on the ground
and go work with elected officials
um along the way I've got a couple of
kids and they started asking me what I
do for work all day and I struggled to
know how to teach them or talk to them
about these ideas that literally went on
Amazon trying to find like books that
talk about free markets or property
rights there was nothing so with my
partner Elijah who's our illustrator uh
we launched the Tuttle twins in 2014.
we've now sold 5 million copies of these
books that teach the rising generation
about things like individualism free
markets property rights and the ideas of
human flourishing so I'm I'm because I
had such a poor schooling experience and
as a father
education is a huge issue and focus for
us because I feel like we're not going
to save our country at the Capitol we're
not going to save our country at the
courtroom we're going to save our
country at the dinner table with
families learning and talking and
debating some of these ideas together
rebuilding the community and the social
fabric that we're talking about that's
how we save our country not the
government not the nation but but our
country is a people and as a community
so I I dedicate a lot of my time to try
and raise the warning voice Corey and I
are in particular with this book but
then also offer up Solutions and help
families learn about the ideas of
freedom
um what uh can you talk a little bit
about what what was it like
homeschooling kits because
um you know that's you know that's a
it's a lot of time to spend with your
kids for them to spend with you and
you're working and things like that just
you know kind of what was the emotional
experience or the day-to-day experience
of it
um well I I think it was it is a an
investment of time it is a sacrifice uh
typically works best in a two-parent
household where you can juggle schedules
or if you have a stay-at-home Uh uh Mom
type of situation but what we are huge
fans of and what are exploding across
the country are homeschool co-ops
effectively they're kind of micro
schools but rather than a teacher or a
few teachers who are being paid it's the
parents coming together so for example I
did classes for the teens on public
speaking persuasive writing uh history
critical thinking and and other topics
as well you might have a mom who was a
biology major in college who can do a
little science class for the kids and so
parents again Community coming together
to pool their resources and their
knowledge and then educate you know
dozens of kids all at the same time uh
those are exploding all over the place
they create great bonding opportunities
for the parents especially the moms
where they can go do you know moms
nights out and social events and so
forth and so that is kind of
homeschooling 2.0 it's the traditional
sit at home and your kids are just you
know being taught by Mom now it's
getting out with other families going to
the park playing together learning
together and that I think provides the
social element provides the peer element
but then you get exposure not just to
Mom or Dad teaching you but to a variety
of adults and so that's something we
leaned into heavily in a lot of families
across the country who homeschool are
doing co-ops right now as well yeah
um let's uh just to kind of wrap up uh
uh Corey why don't we start with you can
you uh talk a little bit about uh what
he you know what's the what's the
direction of school choice what what is
happening now that is uh most exciting
to you and uh you know when when are we
gonna see a change that is uh you know
that gets us out of 90 9 out of ten kids
going to uh Public Schools yes uh School
choices reached escape velocity we're
seeing a universal school choice
Revolution that is ignited right before
our eyes mostly in red States right now
uh but we're freeing families from the
clutches of Randy Weingarten and the
teachers unions once and for all and
there's not a dang thing that they can
do about it I think from what I see what
I see going forward is more of the red
State domino Domino's will fall we've
had six go all in in just two years uh
Arkansas
um Arizona West Virginia Iowa Utah and
most recently Florida that's over 10
percent of States go going all in which
means All Families eligible whereas
previous proposals have been more
incremental
um victories and when you say all in
explain what that means
I mean all families eligible being able
to take their kids state-funded
education dollars to the public private
Charter or home-based education option
of their choosing so that's a lot of
momentum in a very short amount of time
and I don't think it's going to stop and
we're seeing a lot of red state
competition so there's Nebraska that's
passed that's still moving the ball down
the field we have uh Texas uh where I
live now their Senate passed a bill it's
kind of moving through the house right
now and the governor is pushing it
harder than I've ever seen before so I
think once more red States fall some
blue states are going to have to come
along as well Democrats if they keep
opposing parental rights and education
they're either going to lose their
elections or they're going to start to
read the tea leaves and say maybe we
should support this too and I think the
more that the GOP lean into parental
rights as a political winner in the
short run the more that in the long run
will become a bipartisan issue and we're
seeing some trickles of this happening
already that and look Milton Friedman
said it best that it's not about putting
the right people into office it's about
creating a climate a public opinion
where it becomes politically profitable
for the wrong people to do the right
thing and we're seeing some democrat
defections Josh Shapiro in Pennsylvania
right before the election he was up
double digits in the polls but he still
felt compelled to put education savings
accounts in his education plan right
before the election JB pritzker in
Illinois a similar situation he was up
by a lot
um right right before the election he
responded to a candidate survey
supporting a private school choice
program out there that he had previously
vowed to get rid of in back in 2017 and
2018. so we're seeing them either
reading the tea leaves or perhaps some
Democrats are having a true change of
heart which I I wish that would be the
case but it doesn't really matter at the
end of the day whatever the reason is uh
that it's going to be good news for for
parents going forward and uh perhaps
we'll have some victories in blue states
too yeah Connor what about you what
what's most exciting to you uh in terms
of school choice
um I'll answer with a brief story right
after we conclude here I'm going to be
picking up my phone and ordering lunch
using doordash I'm gonna get uh what I
want how I want it when I want it and
where I want it
um
to answer your question then what most
excites me is the individualism that
we're going to see flourish as a result
of this kind of changing world that
we're in I think individualism like
doordash ubereats uber and Lyft right
rather than going to have to wait on a
bus's schedule and sit there at the bus
station and then get on the bus and have
to stop along the way hey I can have an
Uber pick me up where I want and take me
to where I want to go and I think that
becomes very addicting for people who
get used to doing things their own way
we start to increasingly question A
system that requires us to conform to it
and that's that's the downside of the
modern education system the government
schools require kids to conform to it
rather than being flexible and adapting
to the differing desires and
circumstances of kids so especially as
the economy increasingly moves in a more
individualized customized Direction I
think that's going to have a huge
trickle-down benefit to parental Styles
and approaches and education especially
as we see Mike schools and these other
systems flourish in part
incentivized by the laws that Corey and
I have been talking about and pushing
for so I I and as a Libertarian I love
that too because I think that has kind
of fringe benefits of helping people
understand at a more conceptual level
that the economic aspects or the
educational aspects of individualism
have political ramifications as well so
I think directionally that that's what
most excites me right now is there
anything uh Conor that um you know what
what is the thing that will derail
school choice if if you've got momentum
uh you know the the Uber Eats the lift
cars they're leaving the station they're
going to pick up people what I don't I
don't want to say the train is leaving
the station because the train is a
centralized convance which runs on its
own schedule so uh what might derail
this if anything
the thing that worries me having just
gotten an Esa law passed in our state
what keeps me up at night and what I
think it will could derail this is low
demand in other words we have a lot of
paper successes right now we've you know
Utah and half a dozen other states so
far have passed Esa laws great right
those exist on paper
um now it's time to show there's
actually parental demand now it's time
to attract the attention
um of many of these families and so as
these programs come online as they have
been in Arizona West Virginia and others
um I think the narrative is very
important especially given the
historical dominance of the teachers
unions and others and the attacks on
school choice we we need a strong
narrative we need some kind of moral
High ground and an army of people saying
want this we love it we're going to
defend it and if we don't have that Army
if our opponents can look and say oh
look all of that money and all that
effort for you know 10 000 families big
what
um I'm I'm most worried about uh you
know the paper success
how do you how do you uh grow that
demand how do you or how do you have is
it advertising is it marketing uh what
you know what do you do to increase that
demand
um you know I think a lot of it is word
of mouth when uh moms and Facebook
groups are saying oh my gosh I just got
a thousand bucks for my kids to go to
this awesome new micro school that
opened up I think that has a strong
component what we're planning on for
example throughout the summer and fall
uh in our state is a lot of kind of town
halls especially in lower income
communities handing out leaflets saying
hey come learn how your kids can go to a
high quality private school online ads
and really just trying to build the the
email list in the community so that when
the program launches we've got a ton of
people waiting at the gate to say hey
let me in I want to apply and then that
will create its own trickle-down
narrative with earn media attention and
others to say oh wow like the computer
crashed I mean I think in Arizona Corey
would know but yeah they launched their
computers crash yeah right yeah Corey
what about you what is uh finish that
story and then what what are you worried
about in terms of yeah they went from 10
000 people using the program last year
to right when they opened the floodgates
and went fully Universal they now have
over 51 000 people signed up and just
you know less than a year and that's
students or households or what that's uh
students and so I believe it's almost
five percent of the the the school-aged
population in Arizona so that's that's a
pretty significant shift in a short
amount of time and that the program
opened up the expansion opened up to
everybody after the school year started
uh last year so if it was if it was
timed out better I would expect there
would be even more people that would
have signed up
um so I I think Conor's right getting
people signed up for the program is
important I'm more and you know I don't
really care like if if everybody is
eligible and
um you know not everybody signs up I'm
okay with that I don't have like a goal
as to how many people should sign up but
there is a benefit to signing people up
and that you create a new voting block
for when uh if if someone in power tries
to take that away well if there's no one
using the program yet it's easier for
them to take away but if you you have a
new constituency it's really hard for
them to to come out and rip those
scholarships out of the hands of parents
so that's that's a huge benefit and as
far as derailing I don't think there's
any derailing there's going to be forces
that try to derail it that the teachers
unions are going to try to do it
um but the more that we keep knocking
down the dominoes and more people start
to use it and we can show that this
doesn't destroy the public schools that
the in the fear-mongering will will go
have to go away they'll still try
they'll still try to make that case that
this will you know if we do it here I
know it didn't happen in these other
states it's going to destroy our public
schools for X Y or Z reason it's going
to become less and less of a compelling
narrative
um and so yeah I I don't see any real
threats
um I'm very confident that we'll
continue to win and one of the reasons
I'm super confident is that school
choice it's always been the logical
winner it is now a political winner too
and
um in afc's uh 76 percent of the
candidates that were supported by AFC
and our Affiliates won their races in 22
2022 so there wasn't a red wave or a
Blue Wave but there was a school choice
wave and I think that's going to
continue because this is ultimately a
battle about parental rights and uh the
side who wants to say that I don't think
parents should be telling schools what
they should teach the side that's going
to say that the kids and the money meant
for educating them belong to the
government Schools they're going to
ultimately lose because parents they
want the most the most safe for their
own children they're in the best
position to make those decisions for
their kids and so I think we continue
this momentum
um despite the best efforts of the Union
and there will be some people
fear-mongering from the right too and
we've seen some of that recently but I
don't think anyone really takes them
seriously and
um the the bills have taken their
considerations seriously by putting in
explicit Provisions against regulations
against
um government control of of private
education
um so at the end of the day when you
weigh all the costs and benefits most
people are going to see that school
choice is an incremental step in the
right direction
well I hope you're right you know the
big loser of course will be uh you know
all of the uh people who write novels
movies make record albums like Pink
Floyd's wall you know what what will we
do when we no longer have you know a
warehouse of awful memories from K-12
education uh to produce content about
um it's uh you know it'll it'll be a sad
day I suppose uh but one that I'm
looking forward to I want to thank uh my
guests today uh core DeAngelis and Conor
boyak the authors most recently of
mediocrity 40 ways government schools
are failing today students uh check out
you you'll find links to everything they
do in the show notes and things like
that but uh Corey Connor thanks so much
for talking to reason
thank you thank you Nick
and okay
um and